gender id disorder i think is what this
stands for gender id disorder says the
mind is the issue and the solution is
therapy
while gender dysphoria says the mind is
fine it's the body that's the problem
that's an interesting frame that is an
interesting frame yeah
um this shift doesn't seem scientific
but ontological
also true
if the issue concerns the essence of a
right mind wouldn't compelling pronouns
be imposing religious beliefs on people
that's interesting
i'd never thought to frame
either and you know this doesn't
represent all sides but either of these
particular sort of philosophical
approaches um this way and um
if someone thinks that that's not an
accurate framing
i'd be very interested to hear it
uh but
i think it's a it's a framing definitely
worth
spending some time yeah i mean i think
the way that i've talked about it and
the way i i'm actually in the middle of
writing something about
issues around this um
is that they're you know it's a it's a
mismatch right that you know under in
those very rare cases um where there
really does seem to be a you know a
dysphoria um
i don't you know i don't say the mind is
fine the body is the problem but that
there is you know there's an underlying
you know and
putting aside those rare cases that are
actually intersex those slightly more
common cases of trans without being
intersex
um
it's not that the you know that either
one is fine and the other one isn't good
it's that there is a mismatch that
somehow during development the
complexity of development after the
binary of sex um caused the
caused
i mean i guess i was just gonna say like
how do i i guess i do say it as
the brain understands a different
reality than what the body reveals okay
but um
mind you
i'm just riffing here i think this is a
useful exploration yeah but here's the
place it goes it seems to me
let's put adults aside for the second
right
the problem goes back to what we were
talking about in the main
part of the program which was
the
highly
software-based nature of being a human
and the point is if
the
the body is fine the mind is the problem
version is what one takes seriously
then
the point is for somebody who's very
young the ability to change the software
is actually part of what they're
involved in it is the upgrading of your
software that childhood is about
and so the idea that we are suddenly
going to start altering the bodies of
children oh yeah right makes no sense
but i would say suggest is that the if
you were to choose between these two
models
right this suggests that the mind is the
thing to change
um
is
actually
liable to be better in most cases
because the mind is built to be changed
yes ah now i see where you're going
that's very good yes and that you know
that
that prevent that presents a conundrum
that potentially can be solved
i guess the objection i was going to
have is
if we're talking about doing anything to
children i'm sorry i'm out like i i
don't i'm i'm
i'm not interested in talking about
you know reconciling the stated beliefs
of children with their um you know
obvious phenotype
because children childhood is that time
of exploration and but so let's talk
about adults so let's talk about a 20
year old well hold on so what i would
say what i get out of this if you apply
this model the basic point is in the
case of children i'm not necessarily
saying that there's anything to do but
the basic point is because the mind is
coming to discover who you are and who
it wants to be and it's writing that
program that the and you know this fits
with the fact that lots of people who
have gender dysphoria just have it go
away they don't end up as gender
dysphoric adults so allowing that
process to play out is
the best thing to do for the person
right and that sounds more like it's not
gender dysphoria it's gender exploratory
yep and maybe those two things need to
be separated and so the point is if you
arrive in adulthood
and you remain gender dysphoric then
whatever options are
on the table are really yours to choose
from within reason
but the idea that because adults should
have the right to choose these things to
reconcile a mismatch doesn't imply
anything about what should be going on
with children and that's the really
disturbing disturbing thing that is
absolutely true
[Music]
you